Ang, no, he has no clue.
I can't wait to see his face.
I know, okay,
we're in the other room.
I'm gonna bring everybody in
in just a minute.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I have to go,
thank you.
Okay, bye.
(man)
Happy birthday, bro.
Huh, check it out.
(man 2)
Yeah, wow, thanks, man.
(man)
Hey, it's too bad
Amy couldn't be here, right?
Hey, are you gonna make it
official with her soon?
(man 2)
What?
(man)
Come on, old man,
seven years is a long time.
(man 2)
No.
I mean, at this point,
I feel like Amy's more
just like a friend.
Yeah.
I don't know,
something just changed.
Like, I'm just done.
You ever feel like
you're just done?
Yeah, is it because
of all the weight she gained?
No.
I mean, she's definitely
put on some pounds,
but that's not even it.
Yeah.
Is it the long distance?
No, long distance
is the only reason
we're still together now.
Yeah, oh, man.
It just-- something turned,
you know, just everything
about her makes me sick.
Just like, shut up.
I can't take it.
(Angie)
Come in, everybody.
(man 2)
Hey, Angie.
(man)
What's this?
No-no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no...
(Angie)
Come on, get ready, okay?
Ready? One, two, three.
(all)
♪ Happy Birth-- ♪
Amy?
What are you doing here?
When did you
get back from Iraq?
This isn't working for me.
I, I think we should
see other people.
I met somebody else.
And so I made the decision,
I don't wanna
see you any more.
And this was over.
I paid for this,
I'm bringing it.
No.
Step away from it!
I'm having somebody
come back and get this.